la semaine dernière nous avions révélé
dreux sur ou s'il vous plaît combien
florence foresti avec avait facturé sa
prestation pour les césars à canal+
alors ça a fait un énorme buzz on en a
parlé toute la semaine
florence foresti a cru qu'on s'attaque
elle il ya des féministes contre eut
constaté ken voilà ça n'a rien à voir
nous on était pour que roman polanski ne
viennent pas la soirée et ne soit même
pas nommé je vous le dis j'ai des
conseillers à canal je vous le dis de
maître florence foresti dans l'embarras
et je leur ai dit à un moment je pense
que ça va être mauvais pour elle il vaut
mieux lui dire de ne pas le faire parce
que je pense qu'elle n'a que des coups à
prendre
donc voila et j'ai lu après des articles
disons cyril hanouna a voulu virer
foresti deux semaines avant j'avais
juste dit qu'elle n'avait que des coups
à prendre et qu'il fallait peut-être là
préservé puisque en plus canal+ a acheté
son spectacle et donc voilà on a attendu
on a attendu et on avait dit que montant
total tourner autour de 120 mille euros
florence foresti m'a répondu aujourd'hui
une semaine après cher cyril j'ai gagné
18 villes 500 euros pour préparer et
présenter les césars comme vous avez
l'air fort bien renseignés sur les
salaires sur les salaires de mes
prédécesseurs vous pourrez sans doute
lancer un débat sur l'écart salarial
entre les hommes et les femmes lors de
votre prochaine émission bijoux à berne
florence avec plaisir on pourra lancer
ce débat si vous voulez vous pourriez
même venir puisqu'on vous invité de
nombreuses fois dans toutes nos
émissions
elle n'a jamais voulu venir que ce soit
dans la grande d'arca sur la grosse
rigolade
nous confirmons donc aujourd'hui je vous
le dit et on a eu canal+ au téléphone
c'est sûr que florence foresti a bien
facturé via sa société 120000 euros à
canal plus maintenant c'est devenu une
guerre
cette histoire de salaire de florence
foresti nous révèle le salaire on joue
le redis on est une émission médias on a
rêvé les salaires de tous les
chroniqueurs ici on a révélé le salaire
de plein de gens de télé réalité on a
révélé le salaire de tous les gens de
danse avec les stars
voilà qu'on a pu reprendre sur public ou
sur d'autres journaux et aujourd'hui
nous on révèle le salaire de florence
foresti 220000 euros à canal + alors je
vous le dis on a pour comparer
puisqu'elle la demande et florence
foresti sorti les salaires de toutes les
personnes qui ont présenté des césars
depuis 2012 et vous allez voir
et ce sont les salaires officiel je vous
le dis s'il le faut ou les montrera à
long terme sous le livre a choisi
puisque on a tous
en 2012 c'est antoine de caunes qui
était le présentateur des césar il a
touché
antoine en 2012 30 3750 euros en 2013
c'est encore antoine de caunes
il a touché la même somme cécile de
france qui était la maîtresse de
cérémonie a touché 30 1945 euros la
saison d'après en 2015 c'est edouard
baer qui est à la présentation 40000
euros en 2007 et florence foresti 50000
euros
jérôme commandeur qui a pris les
commandes de la cérémonie en 2017 55000
euros
manu payet 45000 euros l'année dernière
kad merad ou ajouts dit on a n'a pas
exactement le montant après armand sur
une seule voie la plus proche des 80
milles sous le dit à cent mille ou alors
ce qu'on a mis ou à la peu près je vais
vous dire comment ça se passe florence
foresti à la toucher 120 mille euros qui
lui ont été donnés à sa société
après quand florence foresti dit j'ai
touché 18 1500 euros c'est ce qu'elle se
serait reversé juste pour la soirée des
césar pour sa prestation le soir même en
direct après forcément à la touche à la
tournée des magnétos elle a voulu je
vous le dit son réalisateur qui est son
compagnon sur sa bande annonce c'est
elle qui l'a payé via sa société
donc forcément après elle fait ce
qu'elle veut des cent vingt mille euros
mais en tout cas canal+ a facturé à
florence foresti et à donner cent vingt
mille euros à florence foresti
après il ya les droits d'auteur en plus
je vous le dis qu'il s'ajoute à ça et
qui vont s'ajouter je peux vous dire que
sur canal+ les droits d'auteur en direct
pour des sketches je peux vous dire
c'est environ 2500 euros la minute
1h 1010 droits d'auteur pouvez vérifier
dominateurs donc voilà donc qui seront
pour elle et pour les auteurs voilà donc
moi vous savez moi je révèle moi je dis
les choses
voilà donc florence foresti j'ai rien
contre elle je trouve que son combat
voilà il est tout à fait louable et nous
y fit je vais vous dire un autre truc
puisqu'elle parle de salaire entre les
hommes et les femmes
on voit que c'est fini ici celles qui
gagnent le mieux sa vie autour de la
table c'est pas une fille c'est pas un
garçon c'est une fille c'est valérie
benaïm 1
ah oui bah c'est normal le fait qu'elle
ne va pas débattre là dessus je suis
très heureux que ce soit d'aleri parce
qu'elles le méritent et qu'on lui a
proposé parce qu'il n'y a pas photo 1
exactement l'aurais je suis très heureux
que ce soit valérie donc lens qui veut
déplacer le débat sur le salaire de
femme
ici il y aura toujours une parité des
salaires et nous une parité même dévoila
de la présence hommes femmes ici ce qui
prime c'est le talent florence foresti
juste je vous le dis dix-huit mille cinq
cents euros
c'est fou c'est peut-être ce qu elle
sait ce qu'elle a décidé de se donner
elle même via sa société
mais canal plus et je le redis ce soir
et franchement je m'en fous de rentrer
dans ces considérations a bien donné
cent vingt mille euros à florence
foresti
c'est clair c'est net qui veulent agir
là dessus gilles ce qui me gêne c'est
qu'elle n'assume pas c'est à dire
qu'elle a pris l'argent mais nous on
n'est pas en guerre contre l airbag et
on remet ça je veux pas qu'on soit dans
ces débats mais papa du trinôme et
l'envoie là on donne une info mais on
n'est pas contre florence foresti c'est
parce qu'elle a su ou qu'elle n'assume
pas moi je suis très heureux canal + sur
proposé 120 mille euros florence foresti
je suis très heureux pour elle qu'elle
ait gagné 120 millions non a révélé le
salaire juste parce qu'elle n'est pas
resté jusqu'à la fin c'est tout on s'est
mis à la place de canal+
on l'a pas enfoncé on s'est dit est ce
que canal+ a le droit de se retourner
vers la mal puisqu'elle n'a pas fini la
soirée et eric naulleau a quelque chose
de choquant ce que l homme est la même
le débat sur la parité hommes-femmes
laissant les hommes femmes
et quand on voit la courbe au wac c'est
elle qui a été le mieux payé moi j'ai
bien sûr moi je comprends pas très bien
le système de mots si je comprends de
défense là et je vous le dit florence
j'ai tous les chiffres je suis de canal+
giuly on est dans le doubs 5 va pas dire
des bêtises florence voilà on est
d'accord canapé tourner sa voix de
travail et des auteurs ah oui c'est très
bien de gens à la patrie elle somnole et
si on lui donne ses séquelles et qu'elle
dément elle a un talent inouï oui mais
oui mais pas sans cause c'est à dire
elle n'a pas à mentir dr sur son salaire
c'est tous et c'est nul
murray joue 10 au lieu de ça elle sait
sûrement payé aussi pour les magnétos
cas là c'est avec janot mais la paix des
hauteurs mais elle s'est payé ça pour
chaque journée de tournage elle s'est
payée à la raison kenan c'est la somme
sur scène mais ce n'est pas la seule à
tous voilà et elle n'a pas compté
également les droits d'auteur qui lui
sont versés en juillet juste c'est ça
que je trouve dommage d'annoncer 18000
alors qu'on sait que c'est pas vrai oui
c'est bête et que c'est pas vrai puisque
nous car elle plus c'est ici ils veulent
te fournir les preuves ils vont tous les
fournir les preuves
maj on remet pas son talent en cause et
bien sûr qu ségalen évidemment qu'elle
fait rire florence foresti mais des
débats de wella parité entre les femmes
et les hommes les salaires aussi
qu'alain puces a vraiment donné 120
donner après après florence elles ont
fait ce qu'elle fascine dans huit de
devant n'a pas déjà ce qu'elle doit
faire si elle veut donner un réalisateur
20000 euros à lui donne un minot mots
justes elle a touché 120000 euros mois
par exemple on m'aurait donné cent vingt
mille euros pour laisser d'adressé au
cas magnéto j'aurais payé personne je
réfléchisse la présentation mais c'est
vrai nom mais voilà donc ya pas de biba
donc je vous le dis la somme est vrai
donc il faut arrêter de nous faire
passer pour des menteurs si elle veut
florence foresti venir débattre avec un
des salaires hommes femmes
elle est la bienvenue sur ce plateau ça
bien on l'a invité maintes et maintes
fois elle n'est jamais venue
alors que même elle voulait travailler
dans le groupe canal et je vais vous
dire moi c'est ça que j'ai pas accepter
aussi c'est que florence elle n'a fait
aucune émission elle aurait dû faire au
moins mouloud qui est mon pote aussi au
moins sur clic mais l'a fait aucune
émission et je trouve que vis-à-vis de
canal+ aussi c'était pas fair-play de ne
pas faire la promotion des césar voilà
je vous le dis oui j'ai appris et en
plus je on sait on s'est toujours bien
entendu et je trouve qu'elle a un très
gros talent oui une question poil à
gratter si on peut remettre juste le
graphique est ce que vous pensez que les
autres ils ont été payés en faction en
salaire mais pratiquement tous on
facture
nous sommes d'accord vous avez joué vous
avoir vara pour savoir la voix ils ont à
peu près tous des housses voilà tous des
sociétés âpres et peut-être qu'une
action salaire mais voilà c'est à peu
près voilà elle en tout cas florence
foresti
on est passé par une société appelée on
lui a donné cent vingt mille euros c'est
sûr et certain
après on a fait ce qu'elle veut elle a
aimé llc donné 18 1500 euros juste pour
la soirée des césar après elle s'est
payé pour les différents manier tout de
même mieux à la facture fournisseurs
péan facture merci là c'est le comptable
moi je voudrais revenir juste sur un
petit tweet qui m'a fait bien rire c'est
bien sûr c'est mon poto booba tout
j'embrasse fort qui a mis un petit tweet
sur cette affaire qui à mi temps a pas
marre d'être en clash avec tout le monde
grandit un peu franchement avec des
smileys et un coeur voilà je t'aime
seurot merci avec toujours là et tu sais
que je te diffuseur ou c'était très
ferme à ça